walking around portland the other day in
oregon i walked past a pedestrian
overpass that had writing on it it was
words that sort of extol the virtues of
the city i don't remember what it said
and i can't find it on google maps now
but it reminded me of a recent episode
of the podcast 99 invisible it's roman
mars podcast about design where he was
talking about the uh
coming upon poetry written on a plaza in
manhattan on the on the gates and how
exciting that was for the people who
found it
and that reminded me of
a trip to florence i took when i was a
kid
finding a plaza a couple blocks down
from the duomo that had an arch at one
side with writing at the top and said i
had to write it down because
i didn't remember in my italian as
terrible i'm sorry but it says atlantico
centro del chita das secolares cualore a
vita nuevo restituito which
thanks to google and some web pages i
know
translates roughly to the ancient center
of the city restored from age-old
squalor to new life
it's a beautiful sentiment right
so i looked up what was going on there
and it turns out that that part of town
used to be a dump it was uh it was kind
of
the a bad part of town that they then
rebuilt into a place for cafes and shops
and nice hotels and when they were done
they put up a sign that said this is
what we did here right we rebuilt this
part of the city
and all that got me to thinking about
the power of inscribing words onto a
cityscape
uh there are other examples of this
right i mean the hollywood sign's a big
one it's essentially this big uh
a big head-up display that says where
you are in l.a
or the lincoln memorial is another one
right where you have a statue of the guy
and then two great speeches on either
side
it's powerful stuff and it put me in the
mind of what an urban planning professor
of mine once said which was that a
successful city tells its own story uh
he was in boston and boston is a city
that man cannot stop telling its own
story right you've got the freedom trail
and the
commemorative plaques everywhere even
the tombstones are living history or
well dead history i suppose
part of that's because i think the per
capita numbers for urban theorists in
boston are off the charts but some is
because the city's
the city knows itself
i actually think though there's
something more significant going on
you know
the human brain's tuned really highly to
see
edges and boundaries right and and
that's if you think about it a way of
looking at cities too it's what kevin
lynch wrote about an image of the city
those are some of the key things that we
think about when we walk around so in a
way when we look at letters when we look
at writing especially if you have a not
an ideographic language but one that
uses letters like english does you're
looking at
highly simplified versions of the city
that we're seeing all around us it
becomes all the more powerful to see
those kinds of things written on the
sides of buildings
now of course
there's signage everywhere right i mean
we see
words and letters written on storefronts
and in shopping districts and on street
signs
when i was living in japan in college
when i was at the peak of my ability to
read kanji which was never very high i
could look at these blade runnery
cityscapes with all the neon light up
signs flashing red and blue and they
contained information for me i could
tell a little bit about what they were
saying but while i was there a friend of
mine came to visit and he didn't speak
any japanese
and i asked him what he saw when he
looked at that same cityscape
without knowing what any of those
ideograms what those images meant
for him it didn't look like information
it looked like art
and i think that's what's important here
is that when we inscribe these letters
on our buildings on the cityscapes when
we literally have
the writing on the wall
we're putting information somewhere but
we're also putting art